Kong Skull Island is a thrilling
reimagining of King Kong's origins
within Warner Brothers and legendary
monster birth and while Skull Island is
packed with awesome action scenes and
monsters there is still a number of
fascinating creatures and scenes
including alternate endings and post
credits which didn't make it into the
final movie
yep UK movie lovers it's Jan here and in
this video I'll be talking about many of
the scenes and rejected concepts we
didn't get to see in the final curse of
Kong Skull Island if you haven't seen
the movie yet obviously there are
spoilers in this video so be aware of
that or check out my spoiler free review
the movie by tacking or clicking here
comscore island has a fantastic opening
scene however what director Jordan Boat
Roberts initially had planned could have
been even more spectacular in an idea
that the director pitch to the studio a
squad of soldiers arrived on Skull
Island in the middle of World War 2
where they start fighting each other
suddenly a huge 8th appears that heavily
resembled King Kong from the 2005 Peter
Jackson movie the soldiers shoot the
giant gorilla dead leaving the audience
thinking they've just killed Kong
himself but then an even larger ape
emerges with a roar by killing off
Jackson's version of communist ultimate
opening vogt-roberts wanted to establish
the idea that the new movie was going to
be very different to previous King Kong
movies however and surprisingly the
studio is not as keen as the director on
kicking the film off in that way Skull
Island was also going to feature a
number of other creatures and monsters
the first creatures that were cut from
the final movie were a pair of
saber-toothed Tigers that would have
appeared the day after Conrad's team and
the sky Devils military unit landed on
the island two enormous saber-toothed
Tigers were going to enter the camp
they'd established triggering a soldier
to shoot and kill one of them which
would have sent the second tiger berserk
killing that soldier the scene was an
alternative way of introducing the idea
that the explorers were setting in
motion events that would disrupt the
local ecosystem they had no idea about
other weird and wonderful creatures cut
from the movie include a monster Venus
flytrap by the way interestingly a Venus
flytrap monster already appeared in the
animated Kong TV series wreck battled
and nearly defeated Kong in the episode
green fear and the art and making of
Kong Skull Island
has some very cool a news concept art of
other creatures and monsters we never
got to see in the final film a number of
unused designs exist the creature
below the water and others that live on
the land although dinosaurs have
featured in previous Kong films such as
the 1933 and 2005 movies vogt-roberts
was adamant that dinosaurs shouldn't
appear in Kong Skull Island the director
said he didn't want to try and rival the
Jurassic Park and world movies and he
wanted his creatures not to feel too
alien like in the end the closer he got
to a dinosaur in the final movie with a
Triceratops skull director vogt-roberts
also wanted the indigenous population
and where they live to feel fresh and
different from previous Kong movies but
before the Erie Village we see in the
final movie two alternative indigenous
settlements were planned the first is
going to be the boat city where people
lived among boats and other ships that
have washed up on the island the second
village was going to be known as Kong
City and it was planned as a traditional
tribal village that was built into rocks
and caverns it was a place where the
people literally worshipped Kong you
would sit like a king on the throne in
front of them the concept art for Kong
city looks epic and although it doesn't
make it into the final movie there is a
nod to the original idea in the stone
paintings of the eerie worshipping Kong
that we see after Conrad and the team
meet Marlow a different ending to the
movie was also considered which would
have featured a bigger role for the
eerie people the alternate ending
involved a desperate action scene with a
team stuck on Marlo's boat while being
attacked by a skull crawler in the scene
the skull crawlers have broken through
the wall and the boat ends up trapped at
the dead end of the river
the only way to escape is for the eerie
villagers to haul the boat up over a
rock face and waterfall and into another
river to get them to safety the scene
was inspired by directors Verna
Hertzog's 1982 film Fitzcarraldo about
her rubber baron who plans to use native
people to drag a huge steam ship over
the side of a mountain in the Amazon
basin as well as an alternate ending
there were also alternate post-credit
scenes in one of them Conrad and Weaver
end up on a boat in the Arctic Ocean
together with Brooke as they watch the
ocean Godzilla suddenly rises up through
the layer of ice
although this would have been pretty
cool the idea was rejected as they
realized the scene would have been
inconsistent with the timeline set in
the 2014 Godzilla movie the main story
in Kong Skull Island takes place in the
1970s and in the Godzilla film it was
reported that Godzilla hadn't appeared
since the atomic bomb
test of the 19:15 now I'd love to know
what you thought about the deleted
scenes and creatures we never got to see
in Kong Skull Island and are there any
kaiju you'd love to see appear in a
future Kong or Godzilla movie let me
know in the comments below if you
enjoyed this and do hit that like button
and why not check out some more of my
movie deleted scenes right here thanks
for watching and see you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers